bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors la france avait déjà
menacé de cette suspension
cela veut dire que le message
aujourd'hui des militaires maliens et
claire peu importe que vous vous
désengager
je ne crois pas que les militaires aussi
sont dans cette situation de
confrontation avec la france
vous avez bien vu que c'est cette mesure
était une mesure temporaire et ce n'est
pas une décision de retrait du bertani
la fin du barca ne le croit que cette
mesure même si intervient dans un moment
de tension entre la france et les
militaires au mali
on a vu très bien que l'as mâcon a déjà
menacé plusieurs fois et a exigé le
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel
mais cette action n'est pas unilatérale
s'inscrit dans un cadre global qui
accompagne peut-être ou complète les
actions de la cedeao de l'union
africaine de l'union européenne des
etats-unis pour mettre peut-être plus de
pression
cela ressemble plus à une décision
politique de pression sur le militaire
afin que l'échéance du 22 février 2000
22h puissent être respectés et que les
élections puissent avoir lieu et que les
militaires ne restait pas au pouvoir
c'est donc un désengagement qui a pour
but de faire pression sur les militaires
selon vous ça va fonctionner ce n'est
pas un désengagement à madame c'est
juste une suspension des opérations
uniquement audi temporaire une
suspension sine uniquement sur l'aspect
des partenariats militaire des
opérations
quand ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'armée française et l'a6 et indiens des
engagements dès lors que la france a
décidé de ne plus travailler avec
l'armée malienne
la femme doit retirer son armée du mali
merci la france ne retire pas sa samba
renée du mali et que si les militaires
au pouvoir ne demandent pas le départ à
des militaires français
cela montre très bien que c'est plus une
décision politique qui mettra de la
pression sur
une pression supplémentaire sur le
militaire afin de les obliger à
respecter le cahier de charge de la
transition en cours alors une suspension
temporaire qui provoque des risques
selon certains la prolifération des
groupes jihadistes est ce que c'est un
avis que vous partagez je ne crois pas
que ça puisse renforcer ces risques
parce que si aujourd'hui on va très bien
on est plus dans un moment où le régime
ou même quand on voit la tentative de
dialogue avec ces insurgés et ces
terroristes est empêché par la france on
va très bien que c'est la france qui ne
veut plus que le mali où ces militaires
puissent discuter ou dialoguer avec ces
terroristes
donc je ne crois pas que le fait que la
france décidé de suspendre ses
opérations avec l'armée malienne
puis ç'a donné l'occasion à c'est un
sujet de passer à la barre
il ya ce risque là pour le moment en
tout cas et je ne crois pas que la la la
l'armée française ou même les autres
armées présentes au mali qui vont rester
bras croisés pour regarder les tories se
déferler sur bamako parce qu'il ya une
tension politique dans le pays
sinon ça c'est l'échec total des
engagements de toutes les forces
présentes à au mali depuis 2013 alors je
ne crois pas que la france prendra ces
risques là et peut être contre cette
décision
nous constatons que vient au mauvais
moment peut-être parce que on est à la
veille de l'anniversaire du mouvement de
5 juin des m5 on va très bien que le
sentiment des français est en train de
monter crescendo au mali et que cette
décision je ne crois pas que puisse
favoriser encore à apaiser ou à calmer
la tension était à ce moment sur cet
aspect là peut-être ça va aggraver le
risque c'est plus c'est sûr côté là à
ses côtés de plus encore les sentiments
qui français puissent encore augmenter
ou qu'on demande le départ de l'armée
française parce que c'est un demain je
crois que demain on va fêter
l'anniversaire de saint camille 25 juin
alors on parle de la france
mais quelle est la marge de manoeuvre de
l'union africaine de la cedeao dont la
crise malienne ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre aujourd'hui quand on
voit très bien que la suspension du mali
qui sont au niveau de l'union européenne
africaine ou la suspension du mali au
niveau des organisations sous régionales
comme la cedeao
s'ils ne sont que des mesures de
suspension il n'y a pas eu des sanctions
telles quelles les sanctions comme les
sarries la dernière fois on a vu au
premier coup d'état
ces militants est vraiment durement
sanctionnés et ont été poussés à ce
qu'il change de position aujourd'hui la
cedeao n'est plus dans cette position de
sanctionner mais ils sont plus dans une
position d'accompagnement pour que ces
militaires de la puce finir la
transition en cours afin de les empêcher
ou empêcher toute tentative de vouloir
changer le calendrier ou l'agenda de la
transition en cours et en exigeant la
libération de l'ancien président du
champion prémunissent et les nommer
promise des civils afin de pouvoir que
faire la possibilité que cette
transition puisse aboutir à un délai
exigé par la cedeao précédemment et je
crois que tous les partenaires sont sur
cette position qui soit à l'union
européenne
même les états unis c'est pas la france
tout seul qui a décidé les états unis
ont arrêté leur coopération militaire
l'union européenne a fait pareillement
donc c'est plus c'est la logique est en
train de se passer un moment dans le
sens où si tous les trois partenaires
internationaux du mali a décidé de
suspendre leur coopération
c'est plus dans l'intention de pouvoir à
mettre la pression politique sur ces
militaires afin que ces militaires
respectent leur engagement à rendre le
pouvoir aux civils en 2020 de quasi
unanimité de la communauté
internationale pour le respect de la
transition c'est que ce n'est pas
forcément un gage de réussite
mais est-ce que vous êtes optimiste pour
la suite au mali je suis en tout cas
quand on faire voir les faits et gestes
de ces militaires et leur détermination
vu le soutien du peuple malien de la
jeunesse malienne et la confiance de
l'ensemble à la société malienne à ces
militaires
je ne crois pas qu'il faille iront cette
confiance que le peuple a mis entre
leurs mains et leur détermination il a
jusqu'au bout et la seule chose qu'on a
on ce pouvoir de 4 qui essaiera de
négocier sur le délai neuf mois pour
organiser la transition peut-être
suffisant ils essaieront de peut-être
dire plus mais je crois que je suis
optimiste que cette transition aller et
ira jusqu'au bout
étant donné qu'aujourd'hui à tous les
partenaires internationaux régionales et
sous régionales et africaines sont sur
la même longueur d'onde de pouvoir
aujourd'hui non pas à sanctionner le
mali parce que vous savez la situation
malienne si le plan sécuritaire est très
très très délicate et fragile
donc ils vont essayer de faire d'une
sorte de ne pas pénaliser le mali et les
peuples malien mais d'accompagner à
d'une façon ferme ces militaires à ce
que cette transition aboutisse parce que
si cette transition
cette transaction n'aboutit pas c'est là
aura des répercussions sur peut-être
d'autres transitions en cours au chat
par exemple
dans d'autres pays en afrique et
allemands dont c'est la crédibilité de
nos institutions africaines et des
partenaires internationaux sur la
question de l'accompagnement de la
transition et surtout la gestion du coup
d'état parce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
cette institution panafricaine et sous
régionales sont très embêtés sur la
question parce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
en train de ne pas respecter leurs
propres principes et règlements sur la
question de plus de pouvoir par les
armes parce que normalement toute prise
de toute prise de pouvoir par les armes
et condamné est rejetée mais on a
aujourd'hui fait des exceptions est ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'exception tchadienne
l'exception malienne ne ne se transforme
pas finalement en principe noble angéla
aujourd'hui ces institutions feront tout
pour que ces exceptions ne soient pas
des principes ou des exemples pour le
futur merci beaucoup avec les rimes
koundougou me rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé au groupe afrique de
l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'europe merci à vous